so clearly I'm here at 30 rock in New
York City on a gloomy almost rainy day
and I've been thinking about something
that a lot of people have been talking
about
let me brace a lot haven't been talking
about a thing that I've been thinking
about tremendously and I kind of just
want to make this statement which is I
don't understand how people don't
realize that they are the patriarch of
their family let me explain everybody
who right now is in let's say 20 to 40
year old range is putting out so much
content through their Facebook posts for
their tweets through their pictures that
they are basically starting the
foundation of Technology digitally
enhanced content is that every
generation I'm talking great-great-great
great-great grandkids are gonna look
back at as almost a starting point I
mean when you look at my family and even
the family it takes the most pictures in
the world there's only so much more
content meanwhile you have a vast amount
of content to me I did Wine Library TV
every day for six years you know that
video is gonna be in place for all my
children and so watching the way people
are commenting and talking about
politics and engaging and the kind of
pictures they're taking and the things
they're doing
if people realize how big this really is
I'm questioning if you realize that
everything you say on the Internet and
every picture you take and I don't mean
from like a bikini shot I mean like
derogatory to someone else your thoughts
and predictions all the dumb [ __ ] till
your grandfather did is lost in history
everything you're doing is being
documented and you are putting the stake
ground for your last name and the
heritage and the legacy of your family I
am for people that consume this video to
think twice not thumb up is this like
just not right from a historical
long-term point of view if you want to
set the tone for your family long-term
legacy my friends is greater than
currency you are the patriarch of your
family